this is a really good question for two
reasons
um i like it because it's a two-year
question someone asked that to me
in the middle of class when we were
doing revision and it's out of it it's
straight out of a two-year paper and it
illustrates really well
the fact that the two unit course
has is not an easy course in itself if
you're an extension one student
you can often get caught up in trying to
understand all the three
concepts and the three unit methods
because they're trickier
particularly on the tree you know
auxiliary angle and general solution and
all the tree expansions
or perms and columns people focus on
that to the neglect of the two unit
course
and then they don't do well on the
tuning exam they wonder why so firstly
just to show that there's lots of good
interesting kinds of
problems in the tuning course and
secondly it's a hard question
but it's hard in the right way this is
what i mean
before i became a teacher i just had two
categories for questions they were
either easy or they were hard but now i
realize
there are lots of different ways for a
question to be hard
for instance if i gave you
or like say when do you learn pythagoras
like in year seven or something like
that
if i gave you a question like x
centimeters
and let's let's put some numbers on this
okay i gave you that question and said
find the value of
x um you could do it
it would be hard but it would be hard
for a silly reason
it would be hard because the numerical
values i gave you
make the question difficult and then
require a lot of
arithmetic precision and then it's not
hard
because it uh tests your understanding
of pythagoras
it's just hard for harm to sick so this
is not a good question
it's hard but it's not a good question
this one on the other hand
it's hard in a very clever way so let me
let me try and illustrate that
it's it's a two-parter so firstly we
have to prove similarity
and secondly then we have to find we
have to evaluate this sub-length down
the bottom
okay so let's do the um let's do the
similarity proof first it's quite
trivial
so what are you given in the question
abc is isosceles the equal
sides are length one you're also given
this angle down in the corner
and you're told that bd bisects
this other angle that's opposite the
base angle so therefore
right away we can say things like for
instance
uh cbd
is 36 degrees and abd
is also 36 degrees
okay because number one it should be the
whole angle is 72 because
equal sides equal angles rather are
opposite equal
and secondly they're both 36 because it
bisects okay
because you've got 72 72 you can use the
angles on the triangle to work out
this one up here it's going to be 36
as well and that's almost all you need
because you can say
look in triangle abc
and getting the order of the
letters right bcd
you've got angle
bhc
being equal to angle cbd we just showed
that both of those
were 36 right so i would have probably
if i've done this properly i would have
proven that above
and written it out but i'm not sort of
focused on the similarity part of this
proof because i think it's quite
straightforward and secondly you've got
angle
dcb
now that 72 is actually in both
triangles right so i just say that angle
is common
once you've got two angles being the
same the third angle must also be the
same because of angles on the triangle
therefore that's all you need to show
that these are similar
and the reason is equiangular
okay so far so good now when you get to
the second one
uh things uh get a little trickier
because there's so little uh actual
length information given to you in the
question
um that you sort of wonder where to
start you may think you might
have the idea that this has to do with
trig okay because you've got all these
different angles here
you do have that length over there you
might notice that because
this triangle is similar you've got
equine angular right you'll find that
this
angle is also sorry not 36
72
so down the bottom if you've got another
isosceles triangle so you have
this side and this side being equal
so then you might notice that ah okay if
that's x
then this should also be x right
then you might look up in this triangle
a b
d right and you'll see okay 36 36 that
leaves me with a hundred and eight
could have seen that through the
straight line as well so you might be
tempted to use sign rule
certainly was not that bad an idea
actually when you think about it
you've got x over the angle that's
opposite is sine 36
right and then your other side is
1 over sine 38 sine 108 sorry
38 okay so therefore you get an
expression for x
which seems like it's a good start
but it turns out that this is not
actually that useful if you want an
exact value
i mean you could evaluate this and
you'll get the correct length that's
that's a true statement
but if you want something precise uh 36
and 108 are not great angles to work
with
um in fact you can work out the exact
phase for sine 36
and hence 108 which is three times
bigger but you end up either having to
use a regular pentagon
or the golden rectangle um because the
golden ratio is involved
and it's more evidence worth to work out
when time 36
and sign 108 r okay so how do we go
about this
trig is not involved okay even though
like it's sort of a red herring you've
got all these angles here
but trig isn't there so how do we solve
this
okay what i'm going to do is i'll often
with similar triangles one of the
hardest things is about vision about
seeing how the triangles relate to each
other
okay so to help us i'm going to draw the
two similar triangles
but i'm going to draw them separate you
can see they're on top of each other
right so if i separate them out
things will be a little easier to see so
you can see here
if i do the big triangle that's a b
c okay you've got your 72's
and down here and your 36 up here your
one
and your x okay now what i want to try
and do is get the two triangles next to
each other and orient it in the same way
so that i can compare the right features
right so
the other triangle bcd should look like
this
and put it upright okay i've got my 272
so you can see i've actually sort of
rotated this
around okay and that gives me a 36 up
the top now
what are the signs that i'm interested
in here well i've got
um x and x
over here that's all i got so far okay
now on the face of it it doesn't look
like there's much
that's useful here for solving x but
this is one of the reasons why this
question is is hard
is because you sort of have to pursue
this line even though it's not obvious
why okay so what can i know about
similar triangles
when i've got these lengths well i know
that there are some sides that are in
proportion
right so for instance i can say cd
on bc so that's
this side here in the smaller triangle
to this side here
okay that ratio should be equal to
this longer side to this little side
right
bc on a b okay and of course
you're doing this rigorously you would
say in similar triangles
corresponding sides incident those are
the same ratio okay or in proportion
um so now if i put in some values here
right
i know what these values are bc is x
uh bc again is x
and a b is one okay so i have this now
this is x squared okay so i have x
squared over here
okay now by the way this sort of makes
sense if you want to visualize it or
think about it this way
this triangle is like this triangle but
it's x times
smaller okay you can see i went from 1
to x
and therefore i should go from x to x
squared that makes sense
now when you come back to our original
triangle how's this useful to us we'll
now have
x squared over here okay and that tells
you that
because this whole ac right is 1.
therefore a d which is left over is
1 minus this part here so it's 1 minus x
squared okay 1 minus x squared
all right now we're almost there okay
remember
this is just a two unit question right
so there aren't many complicated
geometric properties that we need to use
here the last one that i'm interested in
is that abd abd you see it there
that's also a nice sausage triangle
you've got 36 36
here okay therefore you've got a d
and b d being equal a d and b d
equals d
and the reason why is because um equal
sides are opposite equal angles
by the way especially in a question like
this where you've got 50 million
triangles
flying around everywhere if you're
talking about some features of a
triangle you should name which one it is
okay so the triangle i'm interested is a
b d
okay therefore i've got x
and one minus x squared being identical
so if you like bd is kind of like the um
the hinge right on which this question
sort of turns
uh i'm trying to get to that side from
two different angles so from this side i
saw it as x
from this side i saw that's one minus x
squared okay and you can see the
importance of proving similarity in the
first part
okay i'm almost there this gives me a
quadratic okay which is x squared
plus x minus one okay so if you go ahead
and solve this because it can't be
factorized very nicely right you've got
minus
i'm using quadratic formula right minus
b
plus or minus the square root of b
squared
minus four r
a c okay
all over two so just three minutes and
playing there
now you can see here as with most
quadratics you'd expect you get two
solutions right
but you know the x is a length right so
therefore it must be positive
so therefore you can reject one of these
solutions namely the one which says
minus one minus root five but you don't
even have to know what root five
is as a value um you know it's between
two and three to know that
a negative number minus another number
will still be negative okay
so therefore x can't be equal to
minus one minus root five on two okay it
has to be equal to the other one
so this is my answer minus 1 plus root 5
on 2.